FEMALE SPEAKER: Hi everyone.
Hi everyone on the live stream.
I am here today to introduce
Yvonne Pendleton, who
is the director of solar system
exploration research at NASA.
And she began her
career at NASA and 1979,
has a Bachelors
degree in aerospace
engineering from Georgia
Tech, a Masters from Stanford,
and a PhD in astrophysics
from UC Santa Cruz.
She's also a fellow at the
Cal Academy of Sciences
and has an asteroid
named after her.
So please join me in
welcoming Yvonne Pendleton.
YVONNE PENDLETON:
It's my pleasure
to bring you news from your
next door neighbor at NASA Ames
Research Center about what we're
doing in the virtual world.
So the exact title
of our institute,
which we call SERVI for
short, is, as you just heard,
Solar System Exploration
Research Virtual institute.
And it's that last
part, virtual Institute,
that really makes us
different from a number
of other activities and things
that you might hear about.
So I'm going to
go on in a second,
but I'm want to first introduce
to you two of our staff members
that I brought with me today.
We have a small
central office located
at NASA Ames that
helps coordinate
the activities of the
hundreds of researchers
that we have distributed
across the country.
And with me today, I have our
staff scientist Brad Bailey
who's here in the
audience, and also
Brian Day who's our
director of communications
and public engagement.
So when it comes
time for questions,
if you have any
questions that pertain
to either the
activities of our teams,
or the outreach that
we do, they will
be able to help me
answer and go deeper.
OK, so let me just
start by asking,
what is a virtual Institute?
For some of you, you may not
have heard this term before.
Or for those of
you who have, you
may have a different
idea from what
it is that we
actually do at SERVI.
So in our idea, a
virtual Institute
is a distributed
organization that
allows you to pick the very
best investigations, teams
and facilities from
wherever they are.
You don't have to be restricted
by geographical location
for somebody who has a certain
type of laboratory working
with another group
that might have
more expertise in
some other area.
And by sharing the students,
and the facilities,
and the resources that
the various teams bring
to the organization,
you can actually
build a stronger
institute, I maintain,
than if you just had a
traditional bricks and mortar
building.
So I think you get more
bang for your buck.
The small office that we have
that NASA Ames Research Center
is able to coordinate and
help the collaboration,
both within the teams and
across the team lines.
And we're able to do this
across a very interdisciplinary
subject area.
And I'll tell you more about our
subject area in just a minute.
But first, I want to
tell you that there
is a history of virtual
institutes at Ames.
NASA has started the NASA
Astrobiology Institute,
which began in 1998 at Ames.
It's still going very strong.
And then in 2008, the NASA Lunar
Science Institute was born.
That is actually the
predecessor for SERVI,
and we have taken our
studies of the Moon
and expanded them now to include
studies also of near Earth
asteroids, and
the moons of Mars.
Then, we also have to NASA
Aeronautics Research Institute,
which began in 2012.
And SERVI was just born
last year, well in 2013,
a little over a year ago now.
OK, so this diagram,
this drawing,
is indicating the orbits of most
of the near Earth asteroids.
I say most because
we think we have
found most of the large ones.
But there are probably still a
few that we don't know about.
And when you see that
kind of involvement
of where they are located
relative to the Earth,
I think it becomes obvious
why NASA felt the need
to expand our purview to go
beyond studies of the Moon.
And that's why we now
include, as it says here,
the near Earth
asteroids, and also
the moons of Mars,
which we believe
may have been captured
asteroids themselves.
This institute is funded jointly
by both the Science Mission
Directorate at NASA
headquarters in Washington, DC,
but also the human exploration
side what NASA does.
And so, this is a
very important bridge
to join together science
and exploration so that you
are addressing the
science questions you
need to know before you go.
So before we take humans
anywhere beyond low Earth orbit
again, there are certain
questions we want to address.
And our teams are looking at
what those conditions might
be that will help us get
there, and get there safely.
So in more detail what
does SERVI actually study?
Well, we have a long
list of items here,
but the role of
the Moon is still
very important to what we do.
We study the origin,
the composition,
the dynamics of all
of these bodies.
So we'd like to know,
in particular, what kind
of questions cover
multiple bodies.
In other words, if you
were interested in the dust
or the regolith that sits
on the Moon's surface,
you might have some of
the very same questions
that apply to the moons
of Mars, Phobos and Deimos
and similarly to asteroids.
And by understanding the
composition of these materials,
you would better be able
to design both vehicles
and environments for humans to
live in on any of those bodies,
or even just to go there
for a short time to work.
Volatiles.
In its broadest sense,
these are materials
that may be able to be
liberated up from the surface,
or ice from down deep
inside of a crater.
Those are very
important to us as well.
And they cover, again, the
multitude of the bodies
that we study.
And you can read down this list
a number of the other areas
that SERVI is concerned with.
So we put out a proposal
a little over a year
ago for teams to reply to.
And from that, we
selected nine teams.
And here are the
principal investigators
that make up the current
composition of the SERVI
Institute teams.
And you can see that the
principal investigators, just
in alphabetical
order here, I've got
to Bill Bottke who is from the
Southwest Research Institute,
and Dan Britt, who is from the
University of Central Florida.
Ben Bussey from the
Applied Physics Laboratory
has just recently been
replaced by Andy Rivkin
because Ben Bussey is now the
chief scientist in the Human
Exploration and
Mission Operations
Directorate at
NASA headquarters.
Then we go on to
Bill Farrell who
is at the Goddard
Space Flight Center.
This is on the East Coast just
outside of Washington, DC.
Tim Glotch who is at Stony
Brook University up in New York.
Jennifer Heldmann from
NASA Ames Research Center.
Mihaly Horanyia at the
University of Colorado,
David Kring who is in Houston
at the Lunar and Planetary
Institute, and Carle
Pieters at Brown University.
So each one of these
principal investigators
put together the very
best team they could find.
They're usually somewhere around
30 to 50 people in number.
And they could be located at
the university or facility
that I just mentioned where
their principal investigator
is.
Or maybe not.
They themselves would
have a distribution
across the country.
And all of our teams communicate
using the virtual technology
that I'll tell you a little
bit about in a minute.
And we get together once
in a while in person,
but by and large these are
virtual communications.
OK, we also have eight
international partners.
Why would international
partners care
about joining a domestic
group like NASA's SERVI?
Well it turns out, through a
no exchange of funds basis,
if they become a
partner with us,
it facilitates their
getting the resources
within their own
country to develop
whatever kind of
program they wanted
to develop that's
relevant to what we do.
Perhaps it's
investigating the Moon.
Or in the case of
Korea, they're very
interested in going to the
Moon with a mission themselves.
Whatever the
country interest is,
if it relates to what we
do with our domestic teams,
we are happy to entertain
a proposal from them.
And so far eight
of them have been
accepted into our
international family.
And then we urge
cross collaboration
between the domestic teams
and international partners.
And that's going really well.
This is a distribution of where
the principal investigators
and the co-investigators are
just for the domestic teams.
And again, just to
give you an idea
that there are a total
of 318 researchers,
including the students.
There are many students that
are involved with these teams.
And the average team
size is roughly 30.
We have one that's
up to 60 in number.
OK, so getting down to
more details about what
these teams actually
do, I've selected
just a few research highlights.
They have many.
I mean each one of
these teams could easily
take up an entire
hour just to tell you
the fascinating
work they're doing.
But let me just give
you a few highlights.
So Dan Britt at the
University of Central Florida
has a team called the Center
for Lunar and Asteroid Surface
Science.
And they study the
physical properties
of regoliths, the
dust that we've
talked about on the surface
of bodies like the Moon,
but also asteroids
and the moons of Mars.
The geotechnical properties,
the micro gravity effects
that you might encounter, impact
ejecta dynamics, hydration,
and weathering of the
near Earth asteroids.
Over time, the four-and-a-half
billion years that these bodies
have been in space, there's
been a lot of weathering
that's happened.
And the charging
and mobilization
of dust on the surface
of any of these
is going to affect any machinery
you're going to put there,
and certainly the
astronauts themselves.
So then, the next
one, Andy Rivkin,
the Applied Physics Laboratory
at Johns Hopkins University.
Their team is called
VORTICES, a very long name,
and NASA loves its acronyms.
So you can see how they
developed VORTICES out
of their name.
But they study
volatiles, regolith,
and thermal investigations.
They look at the sources,
sinks and processes
and the interaction
that various materials
will have with the
regoliths, and the evolution
of that dust on all
of the target bodies.
OK, the group at the
Goddard Space Flight Center,
led by Bill Farrell, this is
called the Dream Two Team.
And the reason it's
called Dream Two
is because Dream One was part
of the NASA Lunar Science
Institute, which I was also the
director of in the last couple
of years before it
transitioned into SERVI.
So I got to know the teams
from the NASA Lunar Science
Institute pretty well.
And I was really pleased that
when we had our peer review
process of the
proposals, it turned out
several of the principal
investigators who
had been leading teams under
the Lunar Science Institute
were selected for SERVI.
So Bill Farrell
was one of those.
And the dynamic
responsive environments
at asteroids, the Moon,
and the moons of Mars
is what he calls Dream Two.
They study plasmas,
the plasma interaction
that comes from the solar wind.
When the solar wind
comes and interacts
with a body like
the Moon, it does
a number of interesting things.
And the fact that we now
see OH all over the surface
of the Moon, and the solar
wind contains hydrogen
as it's traveling and runs
into the regolith on the Moon,
you can see how the
H and the OH can
get together and form water.
So the plasma processes, as
they interact with the Moon
and the other bodies,
are very important.
And you can also
see here that we
have the solar wind
charging of asteroids.
This is something
else that they study.
They model this.
We have a lot of
interesting results
that show the kinds
of things that you
need to think about when
you're looking at the charging
from these kinds
of interactions.
Timothy Glotch from
Stony Brook University
has a team that they
called The Rise Team.
And they do the remote
sensing of airless bodies.
Field operations and metrics
for human exploration,
they look at the reactivity
and the toxicity of regoliths.
These can be
dangerous to humans.
So you know, when the
astronauts were on the Moon,
the spacesuits were
just covered with dust.
And getting back
into the vehicle,
this is a concern, because if
you're breathing in that dust,
it turned out it was a very
sharp, jagged kind of material.
And it can be really,
really harmful
over the long period of time.
So they look at that
and try and understand
what we have to
mitigate against.
They also do synchrotron
analyses of samples.
And they look at volcanics
and impact crater analogue
research.
Which means you go to places on
the Earth that look like good
analogues for places
you want to go in space,
and you try out some
your machinery and some
of your techniques to see
how they would best work.
OK, continuing on
Mihaly Horanyia
from the University of
Colorado, his Institute team,
called Impact, has developed
the world's fastest dust
accelerator.
And this is open to the
entire scientific community
and exploration community, so
that people can take samples
there.
They can try out
new experiments.
And it's really going well.
They're doing a lot
of phenomenal work.
And they have just
built a new ion
gun that simulates the
solar wind so that they
can extend this
research even further.
And here you can see the
penetration and the charging
studies that they do as well.
Carle Pieters from Brown
University, her team
does a lot of interesting
stuff with the evolution
and environment of
whatever destination
we're going to go to.
But I'd like to really
highlight the work that they've
done on the Moon,
because I think
one of the most exciting
results that we've learned
about the Moon is the
fact that it's so wet.
Now, it's wet compared to
what we thought it was.
It was so dry a few years ago.
I mean we thought
it was very dry.
And it's maybe about as
wet as the Sahara Desert.
But that's still lot wetter
than that what we thought.
So to put it all in
perspective, but the water
is in very different locations.
And that indicates it came
from probably at least
three sources, three
different sources.
And the one that we
found inside the crater
when we had the LCROSS
mission-- I'm sure many of you
would remember that a
few years ago in 2009.
This was a mission
that went to the Moon,
deliberately crashed
into a crater,
kicked up, excavated
a bunch of material,
and then studied what
the composition was.
The LCROSS mission, which
was developed at Ames,
revealed that we have
water ice in the bottom
of a crater, the Cabeus crater.
Well, that was
great confirmation.
We were all very
excited about it.
But frankly, I wasn't
all that surprised.
I kind of thought
there would be ice down
in the bottom of a crater.
What I didn't expect
was that we have
water in the rocks that came
up from deep inside the Moon
that the astronauts picked up.
In the Apollo samples, it
turns out some of those samples
that they brought back contained
glass beads, volcanic glass
beads that could protect
the water inside it.
And now, all these years
later, we have the technology,
we have the instruments to go
back and analyze those samples
in greater depth
and differently.
And that's where we found
quite a bit more water
than we previously thought.
And then, the third
component of water I
already mentioned to you, which
is the OH that exists literally
across the Moon in very
different terrains.
And the interesting
thing about that
is that it seems to be
replenished on a current cycle.
This isn't just water that
was deposited a long time ago,
like deep in the crater that
happened a long time ago,
and that's that,
and this is now.
We think we're seeing
actual replenishment
in these different
scenarios, and not
the water deep in
the Moon coming
up, but of the one
on the surface,
and also some of the craters.
And that's fascinating
to me, because that just
changes a lot of
the physics of what
we thought was
happening on the Moon.
And if we understand how
it's happening on the Moon,
we then understand
more about how
it could happen on Phobos
and Deimos, and other bodies,
and near Earth asteroids
that we might go to.
OK, so going on to a couple more
of our teams, Bill Bottke, who
runs a very interesting team
out of the Southwest Research
Institute in Boulder,
Colorado, they
do a lot of theoretical
modeling where
they look at the dynamics
and the formation
of the early solar system.
In fact, in just
about a week I'm
going to be at a conference.
It's all about early
bombardment of the solar system.
And they'll be talking
about what happened when.
What big bodies hit
the Earth and the Moon,
what they did,
when they hit, how
they affected the other
terrestrial planets.
And computer models
can really tell us
a lot about how all
of this happened.
The migration of planets
from the early part
of the solar system to today has
a lot to do with the dynamics
that these bodies
found themselves on,
the trajectories and
that sort of thing.
He also looks at things
like how asteroids
could be stuck together, or
how easily you could pull them
apart.
One of the concerns we have with
asteroids is that some of them
seem to be extremely fragile.
And you don't want to have
a mission to an asteroid
that you go up to, and
as soon as you touch it,
the whole thing falls apart.
And now, you've got a
whole bunch of little,
or maybe not so little, pieces.
And the models that
we have are helping us
understand how that works.
Jennifer Heldmann at
Ames Research Center
is leading a team that she calls
FINESSE, a very nice acronym.
And what she's doing is looking
again into the Earth analogues
that I mentioned just
a little while ago,
so that you can really
understand what you should do
when, if you were out exploring,
both with humans and with
machines.
So for instance, their team
went to a couple of places
in this past year.
And the one that I'd like to
tell you about is in Idaho.
It's called Craters of the Moon.
Maybe some of you have been
to this national monument.
And they looked at the way
you would operate machinery
from a distance, simulating
what it would be like
if you had a back science
room here on Earth trying
to run something on the
Moon, or on an asteroid.
And so, they did take quite a
bit building in the time delay
that you'd have
in communications,
things like that.
Let's see, and the
last team that I'm want
to mention here, David Kring
from the Lunar and Planetary
Institute in Houston.
They study the inner solar
system impact processes.
And you'll see a
similarity in themes
in all the things
I'm saying here.
It's probably kind
of blending together,
like which one does what?
Well, you know what?
That's exactly the purpose.
We want them to blend together.
We want to not see
the lines between what
these different teams
do, because I believe
it's by the collaboration
and the crossover,
what these teams
bring to the table,
that new science gets developed,
new directions are found.
And this is where the
most creative discoveries
seem to be happening.
So what David does is
he looks at the impact
history and processes, the
geochemistry of the regoliths,
and age dating of
regolith materials.
He looks at the near Earth
asteroid identification
and characterization.
And he also works a lot with
the next generation training
of both the young people that
will go into these fields,
and also astronauts, the
new classes of astronauts,
so that they know how to
identify rocks and the geology
side of what astronauts
need to know,
as well as a few other things.
And some of the things
that his team has just
recently finished, they did
a global lunar landing site
database that is now
open and available
for the entire community.
So these teams are creating
materials that are available
not just for the
teams themselves
but to the entire science
and exploration community.
OK, so another thing that we do
it within the virtual Institute
that I really like a lot is
we build and share facilities.
And this first picture
that we have here
is about the dust
accelerator that I
mentioned at the
University of Colorado.
And that was up and
running, actually,
during the Lunar
Science Institute,
because, again,
Mihaly Horanyia was
one of the principal
investigators who
led a team under the Lunar
Science Institute that is now
part of SERVI.
And at Brown University
there's something called RELAB.
This is a spectroscopy lab
where they look at samples
and help people
analyze and understand
what their field
samples are made of,
and the new components
that they make as well.
And at Brown
University, they've also
developed something that is a
3D immersive environment, which
is something that I think
the Google folks would
be especially interested in.
So that you feel
like you're there,
and you look around
in all directions,
and it's just like
you're really there.
This was modeled
after what we call
the KeckCAVES, which
are at UC Davis.
Maybe some of you are
familiar with that.
But they have the
same kind of facility
now at Brown University.
OK.
Oh, wait a minute.
And at Ames we have a
couple of facilities
that we share as well.
There's a regolith
test bed where
we have eight tons of
simulant of lunar material.
And we have little rovers
that run around in this yard.
I use it with students remotely.
They can be across the world,
and they can operate the Rover.
And we've built
in little lessons
where they can go up
and try and identify
the difference between
a meteorite and a rock,
and take pictures of
it, that sort of thing.
There are scientific uses
for the test bed as well.
And at Stony Brook
University, there
is a vibrational
spectroscopy lab.
And this is, again,
something where
people would bring
their samples to it
and try and understand-- or
something that they built
or created-- and try to
understand more about how
it would interact
with or be interacted
on by some sort of process,
and also what it's made out of.
OK, another part
I wanted to stress
is the SERVI team
collaborations that we
have across the team lines.
And so just a
couple of examples.
This one, this first one,
came about in the very first
experience where we brought
the principal investigators
together to meet
for the first time.
And over this two-day period
where they met face-to-face,
we were a NASA
Ames, we asked them
to please come up
with a list of areas
where they thought their
area could cross over
and they could find
a collaboration
with one of the other teams.
We had each of the teams
give a little synopsis
of what their proposal was.
Now, keep in mind,
these were teams
that were competitors
just moments ago.
And now, we're asking
them to share everything.
Share your data,
share your processes,
tell us what you're
going to do, and look
for ways-- trust each other and
look for ways to work together.
And they did it instantly.
And one of the ideas
that came out of it
was to have this
sample repository
at the Natural
History Museum, where
any team that collects
any kind of field sample,
or had a sample that they
made, could bring it together
and put it in one place,
so that if you wanted
to do some sort
of process on it,
you could know that you
were using the same rock.
Two different teams doing
two different processes
on the same sample
is a lot better
than using two entirely
different samples that you just
happen to think are the same
rock, or the same material.
And this one ran into just
a little bit of a hiccup,
because it turns out the
Natural History Museum does not
take samples that
are found on Earth.
But they only take
samples that you create.
So we're looking for another
home for the actual field
samples at this point.
But this was a
great idea, and they
started putting all their
materials together right away.
And I was just really pleased
to do that, to see that happen.
And another one is
the asteroid modeling.
So the dynamics that
we talked about with
the early solar system
and what happened to it
when you had all this
bombardment in the early days.
When you couple that
to geochemical studies
of the rocks that
people have found,
either from meteorite samples
that have come off planet
from someplace else, or the
lunar samples that came back
from the Moon, you couple that
together with the dynamics,
and you can learn an awful
lot about what happened when.
And what we call the
late heavy bombardment
period that affected both
the Earth and the Moon system
is one of those times
that we'd really
like to understand better.
Because it looks very, very
likely that the moon formed out
of a giant Mars-- not
giant, but a Mars-sized body
hitting the Earth.
And when it hit the
Earth, it knocked off
a great deal of material.
And out of that formed the Moon.
But what didn't make
sense for a long time
were the isotopic
studies that we
had in the chemical composition
between the Moon and the Earth.
Those are now coming
into much clearer focus
in terms of how hot the Earth
was, how wet the Earth was,
how big that body was, what
kind of angle that body had
to hit the Earth at in
order to make what we end up
seeing on the Moon.
So it's just amazing that
dynamicists and geologists
getting together are making
these kind of strides forward.
I mean those people
would not even
have gone to the
same conferences.
So they wouldn't have met,
they wouldn't have talked,
they wouldn't have
shared down to this level
the kind of research
they're doing.
And now they are,
and out of that
grows new science
and new discoveries.
So isn't that cool?
So let's see, I've
already said this
about facility sharing
and sample analysis.
So I will skip that.
We also ask that the
international partners
collaborate with
the domestic teams.
And so, that Crater of the
Moons campaign that I mentioned
that Jennifer
Heldmann was running,
and Timothy Glotch, his team
was part of that as well.
That also had our Canadian
partner as part of it.
The dust accelerator
that I mentioned,
that was built with our
partnership with Germany.
So we can see an awful lot of
the international flavor coming
through as we move forward
with first the Lunar Science
Institute and now with SERVI.
So now I'd like to mention
the resource prospector
mission for just a second.
SERVI has several people
in an among our teams
that are actively
engaged in this.
And Terry Fong who's here in
the room today from NASA Ames
is the deputy manager of
the rover part of this NASA
mission.
This is a mission
in development,
with the idea of
developing technology
that's generally applicable
across many different target
bodies.
But ostensibly, it
would go to the Moon.
And the proposed
mission demonstrates
in situ resource utilization.
In other words you would
collect and use the materials
that you find on the body.
And various critical
mission aspects
are being developed
at NASA Ames.
It has a lunar rover carrying
the Regolith and Environment
Science and Oxygen and Lunar
Volatile Extraction payload.
Oh my gosh, that's a
ridiculous acronym name.
It's called RESOLVE.
OK, and preliminary
testing has been conducted
on Mauna Kea in Hawaii,
one of my favorite
places, in conjunction with
the Pisces group there.
Anyway, SERVI is facilitating
the site selection and analysis
activities for this mission, and
a number of our investigators
are involved.
And we're very excited.
We hope that this
mission goes forward.
OK, there are a lot
of words on this page.
Main point is I
wanted to tell you
that our central office does a
whole lot more than just send
out the money.
Our institutes, each
one of the teams,
are funded for five years, which
gives them long term stability.
And that's great for them.
But what we also try
to do is make sure
that we at the central office
take care of the big problems.
Anything that would slow
them down and take them away
from their research,
we would like
to handle in the central office.
And then, beyond that,
the actual running
of the Institute, we do an awful
lot of community engagement.
Our job was to
bring together the
scientific and the
exploration community.
And again, those are groups
that don't often mingle.
But to show them that
they had a lot in common,
and they had things
that they needed
to learn from each other.
And so to do that we have a
lot of various activities here.
MALE SPEAKER: All right, so
we have a number of things
that we're doing to
keep ourselves busy.
We have the Exploration
Science Forum.
You're going to be
hearing more about that,
but that is our
annual conference
that we have at NASA
Ames where we have people
from around the world
gathering and talking
about lunar and planetary
science and exploration
technologies.
We also help coordinate
a European conference,
the European Lunar
Symposium, with our partners
that we have in Europe.
In terms of citizen
science, we've
been working successfully.
We've been involved with the
LCROSS and LADEE missions,
involving amateur astronomers
and citizen science
in actually making
observations that
contribute to the
science of the mission.
For instance on
the LADEE mission
we had a number of amateur
astronomers observing the Moon
during the course of
the LADEE mission.
As LADEE is flying
around studying
the atmosphere of
the Moon, we were
looking at meteoroid impacts
on the surface of the Moon,
seeing how those meteoroid
impacts would correlate
to changes in the structure
and composition of the lunar
atmosphere.
We're working on opportunities
for amateur astronomers
to actually be measuring the
orbits, measuring the positions
and changes in the orbits, of
these near Earth asteroids.
That's very important, because
they don't feel constrained
to be limited just by
Kepler's laws of motion.
That makes them tricky.
We're working with
the SETI Institute
just down the road
here in a program
where people have very simple
security cameras pointed up
at the sky.
They're allowing them to
record meteors as they come in.
And if you get enough people
from slightly different sites
recording that
meteor, not only do
you see it's three-dimensional
path coming down
through the atmosphere,
you can calculate
what its orbit was before
it encountered the Earth.
And that way were discovering
new meteor streams from comets
as yet undiscovered,
but whose orbits
intersect those of the Earth.
And we're working with the NASA
Tournament Lab and TopCoder
Program to develop improved
algorithms for integration
of data from spacecraft.
Recently we've been
working with LRO.
We're looking at
some other options,
but integration of that
data into our lunar mapping
and modeling portal,
which is now branching out
into other planetary bodies too.
Let's go to the next slide.
A fun event that we have that
I would like to invite you to
is the International
Observe the Moon Night.
We've been doing this every
year for a number of years now.
We get people showing up at
locations around the world.
Here you can see Google Maps
is actually showing us right
now where people are
signing up to have events.
Our event this year is going
to be on September 19, 2015.
And people will gather at these
locations all around the world.
We will be streaming out
talks to these locations,
and people gather with
local amateur astronomers
to see the Moon.
It's really, really an
exciting, exciting thing to do.
We have a lot of classroom
visits, workshops,
public lectures.
A lot of these are streamed
out to remote locations
around the world.
We've been working
with Navajo Technical
University on a
number of projects.
They're doing some really
neat work in 3D printing.
Exploration Uplink, Yvonne
talked about our robot
rovers out in our lunar
simulant test bed.
And also in our
simulant test bed,
we're going to be working this
spring with some students who
are working with the swamp works
at KSC, Kennedy Space Center,
on a payload, a
proposed payload,
for Google Lunar XPRIZE Mission.
So they'll be actually
doing some testing
in our simulant test bed there.
YVONNE PENDLETON: All right.
So the other thing we'd
like to invite you to
is the NASA Exploration
Science Forum.
This is something we
host every summer,
and it is in person
as well as virtual.
But since you're
right down the street,
please just hop on over.
We would like you to register,
but it's free of charge.
And it happens in July, the
21st through the 23rd this year.
And it will be three days of
listening to and interacting
with people who are doing
cutting edge science
and looking at how that
science informs exploration.
So please come to that.
We have hosted a number
of virtual events
over the last several years.
I mean since the NASA's Lunar
Science Institute was formed,
we've probably done more than
a thousand virtual events.
And so, you can always
go to our website
and see what's coming
up, what's new.
We have workshops.
We have seminars.
We have various
things that might
attract you and
have some interest.
So go to servi.nasa.gov.
And if you misspell SERVI,
we tried to capture as many
of those domain names as
possible with the misspellings.
Just try to remember SERVI,
it sounds like the disease.
OK.
All right.
Partnerships in Silicon Valley.
We're very fortunate to
be here in Silicon Valley,
and so we try to learn as much
as we can from those of you
out there doing
this cutting edge,
wonderful new development.
And so, we have a picture
there, what's being shown
is a little robot that we
have from the Double Robotics
Company.
And we have a couple of those,
and we use them for people
to attend our forum when they
can't be there in person,
or just to come down the hall
and have a conversation with us
when they're not
physically in the building.
We also do a lot with
next generation support.
That is, training
the next generation.
And Brad Bailey, who's
here in the audience,
has done a great deal of
this for the graduates
and undergraduates
that we work with.
We've probably trained
about 200 graduates
who are now employed in
academic and other positions.
And by we, I don't mean
the central office only.
I mean throughout all of the
teams that we've had as well.
We've established new programs
and promoted new faculty
positions at various
universities,
and established things
like Lunar Grad Con, which
is a conference that is run
by the graduate students
themselves.
But we support them and
give them the encouragement
to do that, so that they
can get used to giving talks
in front of their
peers and get feedback,
and that sort of thing.
There have been student exchange
programs, NASA Post Doctoral
Program where we try to put
in bed a postdoc with two
teams, at least two
teams, so that they
can benefit both teams
and be part of that glue.
Students are that
unique glue that
hold teams together in
a way that I just love.
And I've seen them
grow up in one team,
graduate and go to
another one, and then
become a postdoc somewhere else.
It's fantastic.
So OK, I think you can
read the rest of that.
Let's just go on.
What's our future look like?
Well, we've got the
Exploration Science Forum,
as I mentioned, in July at Ames.
And the European Lunar
Symposium that we also help,
and that is in Rome,
Italy-- Frascati, which
is in May of 2015.
So we're looking
forward to that.
We have our next cooperative
agreement notice.
This is the vehicle
by which new teams
will apply to become
part of SERVI.
I told you that
the current teams
are funded for five years.
Well, every two-and-a-half
years, we'll put out a new CAN,
cooperative agreement notice,
for teams to apply to.
And that way, we hope
to select the new teams
before the old
teams have finished
their first five-year stint.
That will give us
cultural continuity,
and the older teams
and the new teams
will work together better.
We have the potential for
new international partners.
We always hold special
sessions at major meetings
like the American
Geophysical Union.
This past December, we
had an all day session
devoted to science and
exploration topics.
And we hope to continue
the significant inter-team
collaborations.
In the first year of operation,
first year, these teams
have already published over
195 papers, and probably
400 conference papers.
And this is just unbelievable.
I mean anyone who's gone
through the peer review process
knows it takes about a
year to get something out
from start to finish.
And these teams
have already managed
to get 195 papers through
that peer review process.
So we're very proud of
them, and we look forward
to what they're going
to do in the future.
One thing that we thought you
guys might like to hear about,
lessons learned
from our experience
with virtual collaborations.
I haven't talked to you
very much about what we use
or how we do it.
I've got the slides if
you want to know more.
But we use Adobe Connect.
And we found that that
serves our purposes best.
There are many ways
that we could do this,
but that is one
that works for us.
And so, what we've
learned over the years
is that it's really
important to conduct
personal one-on-one training
before we have anybody present.
It's important to
provide a checklist
so that even though they think
they're familiar with how
to turn on their camera
and set things up,
they've got a little
checklist they can go down.
That saves a lot of
time and trouble.
Test, configure, and
optimize the off-site video
teleconferencing system.
This is critical.
We provide a technical
producer and a host MC speaker
who's familiar with what
virtual communications are like.
And that means that when
there's some awkward pause,
or some time, or something isn't
sounding quite right, that MC
knows the right thing to say,
the way to keep everybody
engaged, and the way to
get us through the problem.
We like to have redundant
systems and backup roles
so that there isn't a
single point failure.
That's something we've learned
from NASA and the Apollo
Program.
What experience has taught us.
Create an environment
that's inviting and has
a real natural feel.
Designate a facilitator
for each event.
Use social media and
dedicated online discussion
to involve and engage the online
audience and the participants,
as well as the speaker.
And that's why we like Adobe
Connect, because you've
got that little chat box,
that window where people
can type in their questions.
And sometimes you
see people answering
each other's questions
in the chat box,
while the speaker just continues
on with their presentation.
Now as a speaker, I find
that really disconcerting.
I don't like looking
at that chat box.
If somebody's
asking a question, I
want to be the one answering
it, not having somebody else.
But it turns out a lot of
other people feel differently.
They love having that chat box.
And so, they really use it,
and they go to town with it.
And I have to admit,
it's value added.
And let's see, just
try to accommodate
time zones, that's obvious.
Ninety-minute
sessions work best.
We try and follow those
with a 10-minute break.
And have no more than
three sessions a day,
or you're going to
lose your audience.
And in conclusion, I
think the main takeaways
for what we've learned from
the virtual institute model
is that by having longer
periods of funding--
the five-year funding--
that's long for a scientists
because usually they have to
write proposals for one or two,
maybe three years.
And by giving them a larger
amount of funding-- the teams
each get roughly
$1.2 million a year.
And this enables them to
then support their students.
You can support a
student for five years
and get them all the way
through graduate school,
if they start at the right time.
But by doing this we get
unexpected discoveries
from the interdisciplinary
and inter-team collaboration
that comes about
through this research.
So the whole really is more
than the sum of the parts.
And we see incredible
productivity from these teams.
So we know that the taxpayer,
all of you, all of us,
are getting a lot of
bang for you buck.
The ability to assemble the
best possible team regardless
of where they're
geographically located,
and the cost savings
that you get, obviously,
by not having to
travel everywhere,
both in time and
energy, really, I think,
gets that productivity up.
And the long-term
stability for the students,
our future workforce, this
is so important to all of us.
So with that, I think
that's everything I brought.
And I'm happy to
answer any questions.
And we've got, of course,
Brian Day and Brad Bailey
here as well that are also
happy to take your questions.
AUDIENCE: Is NASA the
first organization
to try this virtual institute?
I thought it would have
been very popular by now.
YVONNE PENDLETON: Well,
that's a good question.
The National Science
Foundation actually
has tried this as well.
I think their model is
slightly different from ours.
But I do believe
NASA was the first.
And I think with the NASA
Astrobiology Institute,
they have the longest running
history, from 1998 to now.
And they are going strong.
So we took a lot of our
cues from what the NAI did.
And I think the NSF, it
probably learned a bit
from what NASA did as well.
But I don't know of
other organizations.
I can tell you that both the
Office of Management and Budget
and the White House had been
interested in what we're doing.
And just about a
month or two ago,
they asked me to get them
a presentation as well,
because they're looking
at how this might
apply to other
government agencies.
So you might see more virtual
institutes in the future.
AUDIENCE: So what's the
typical collaboration schedule
for many of these
collaborations.
Do they all get together
like weekly or monthly,
or is it just like the PIs,
or is it the whole ecosystem?
YVONNE PENDLETON:
That's a great question.
So the question, it could
be answered differently
for the different teams.
They are allowed to
set their own schedule
and do what works best for them.
But I know some
teams that have--
almost all teams have at
least a monthly meeting,
in addition to the
monthly meeting
that they have with us
at the central office.
All the PIs get
together and report
on what their teams have
been doing once a month.
But within their team, they
do at least once a month,
some of them on a weekly basis.
And I think it really depends
on whether their people are all
co-located in one place, or
whether they're spread out
and they need to tag up
with them around there.
But one of the
things that we think
is very important in running
the virtual institute
is not to over constrain
what the teams do.
As a scientist myself,
I know that I really
appreciate the leadership
getting the obstacles out
of the way and letting
me get my job done.
And that's what we're trying
to do with the teams as well.
So when they have new
directions, new ideas that they
want to go down, they
don't have to check in
with us every
minute of every day.
If it's a major
redirect, we'd like
them to talk to
us about it first.
But in general,
if all they do is
what they wrote
in their proposal,
we would be disappointed.
Because we know that new
science, and new creativity,
and new ideas come
at the intersection
of many disciplines.
And those clever
ideas that they get
by having these weekly
or monthly discussions,
however often they
want to do it.
AUDIENCE: So I know a
lot of other NASA groups
still insist on
face-to-face meetings.
Many of the Cassini, things
like that, all that groups
meet together.
Do you think you could
give advice face to them as
to whether such-- everybody
needs to get together
in the same room
is still necessary.
Or do you think those
face-to-face meetings still
have a place?
Or do you think
this is the future?
YVONNE PENDLETON: Sure,
a very important message.
I'm so glad you
asked that question.
Because a very important
message to take away here also
is that virtual is
not always the answer.
And there are some
really important reasons
and situations where you want
to have that face-to-face.
And I know from the
team activities,
my husband, who is also
a planetary scientist,
has been on several teams.
And I've watched
what they have to do
and the way that they
have to interact.
And right now
they're getting ready
for the Pluto
encounter that's going
to happen in July, July 15th.
They're meeting on a regular
basis in person, every month,
or every three to four weeks,
maybe even more frequent.
Yeah.
See OK, you're
part of that maybe?
OK, and so that's critical.
That's critical.
And we are not by
any means suggesting
that this replace
those critical times.
But there are plenty
of other times
where we find that
virtual does work great.
And people ought to
be open minded to it
and give it a chance.
Also, I think the problem is
that when they think virtual,
they might think of some
bad experience they had
where the audio was
poor, the video was poor,
you wasted a lot of time
trying to get people set up.
That is not what we do.
Come and watch one of our
video archived sessions,
or join us for something, and
you'll see the difference.
And part of that
difference is because we
have a technical staff
in the central office
that provides the bridging among
whatever platform you choose
to join in by, or the practicing
with the presenters ahead
of time.
They try to debug it,
so that to the audience
it really looks flawless.
And the audio quality is high,
and the video quality is high.
And your experience
is much better.
Your frustration
level goes way down.
So there are some cases where
it works exceedingly well,
and other places
where I wouldn't
try to replace the
old fashioned way.
FEMALE SPEAKER: All right.
Well, thank you
very much Yvonne.
YVONNE PENDLETON: Thank you.
It's a pleasure to be here.